Les gens ne se bousculent pas
pour travailler dans les champs,
et la pénurie de main-d'oeuvre
est un enjeu bien réel en
agriculture. On cherche
désespérément des travailleurs.
Pourtant, en Montérégie,
des producteurs maraîchers
vivent l'histoire inverse : des
travailleurs de l'autre bout
du monde ont choisi leur ferme
et sont venus les épauler.
♪ ♪ ♪
Deux jeunes garçons rentrent
de l'école. L'un d'eux,
Saku Ikeda, n'a pas grandi
à Mont-Saint-Grégoire,
mais dans un archipel à des
milliers de kilomètres d'ici.
Dans la cuisine, Yoshie, sa
mère, prépare le repas pendant
que Madoka, sa petite soeur,
joue tranquillement. Plus loin
dans les champs, son père
Tatsuya travaille la terre.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Quand on habitait au Japon,
on avait une ferme comme ici,
notre propre ferme maraîchère,
biologique.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Dans la région de Nagano,
Tatsuya et Yoshie louaient
un lopin de terre où
ils cultivaient des légumes
et des fleurs comestibles.
- Au bout de 10 ans, mon
propriétaire m'a dit qu'il ne
voulait pas renouveler notre
contrat. Il fallait quitter.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Cette éviction sera l'élément
déclencheur.
- On a beaucoup réfléchi notre
futur... J'ai pensé que : oui,
maintenant, on part à l'étranger
pour faire une autre expérience
pour moi et pour la famille.
- Ils lancent alors
une sorte de bouteille
à la mer version moderne.
- Ils ont écrit une lettre à
une quinzaine de fermes dans
le monde entier en disant :
«On est prêts à quitter le
Japon. On voudrait s'établir
dans une ferme biodynamique au
moins pour quelques années.»
- Une belle lettre en beau
français, avec de belles photos
de la famille de Yoshie
et Tatsuya, du Japon.
Puis ils disaient qu'ils étaient
intéressés à venir travailler
chez nous, puis tout ça.
Puis j'ai dit à Arnaud :
«On les rate pas, il faut
qu'ils viennent chez nous!»
♪ ♪ ♪
- La Ferme Cadet Roussel,
que gèrent Arnaud Mayet et
Anne Roussel, suit les principes
de la biodynamie. Cette approche
complexe se base entre autres
sur les cycles de la lune pour
déterminer le moment opportun
pour semer et récolter.
♪ ♪ ♪
Si trouver des employés en
agriculture est ardu, recruter
des gens spécialisés en
biodynamie relève de l'exploit.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Biodynamie, c'est très rare.
Puis pour avoir le permis de
travail, c'est plus facile
quand il y a une spécialité ou
quelque chose qu'on peut dire :
«Oui, on reçoit des demandes
de gens qui veulent venir
travailler, mais en biodynamie,
c'est vraiment rare.»
♪ ♪ ♪
- La ferme approvisionne 600
familles durant la haute saison.
♪ ♪ ♪
Elle emploie une dizaine de
travailleurs, dont quelques
Mexicains et un Guatémaltèque.
- On était dans une démarche que
la ferme est grosse pour deux
personnes, à réfléchir à tout
ce qu'il y a à réfléchir.
Ça fait que sans avoir mis
d'annonce de recherche, on était
en recherche de gens avec qui
partager le quotidien, partager
les soucis, partager les tracas,
les décisions à prendre.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Depuis 2019, les Ikeda sont
partie prenante des opérations
de la ferme. Mais si Tatsuya
était décidé à quitter le Japon,
sa femme Yoshie n'était pas
aussi convaincue. Sa première
visite a lieu en plein hiver.
- Première fois pour deux
semaines. Pour moi, c'était pas
du tout sûr de venir ici encore
pour vivre avec les enfants.
J'étais encore fermée.
Parce qu'il fait froid, aussi...
Aussi je n'ai pas eu l'image
de la ferme parce que
c'était avec la neige.
- Finalement, c'est pour ses
enfants qu'elle décidera de
faire le grand saut, pour qu'ils
puissent apprendre une autre
langue et évoluer dans un cadre
scolaire moins strict qu'au
Japon.
- L'ambiance de l'éducation,
c'est un peu différent. Il n'y a
pas beaucoup de devoirs non
plus. Au Japon, c'est chaque
jour les devoirs. Les enfants...
Il faut passer le moment des
enfants. Pour moi, je pense,
il y a les choses plus
importantes que devoirs.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Une fois arrivés, c'est
l'adaptation. Même si le couple
avait déjà séjourné en France
à quelques reprises, la langue
française demeure pour eux
pleine de subtilités.
- L'autre fois, on parlait d'un
champ d'ail, avec de l'ail, puis
un chandail. Puis là, Yoshie a
dit : «Mais c'est le même mot!»
J'ai dit : «Bien, c'est deux
mots, "champ d'ail", mais un mot
"chandail"», puis là c'est
comme... Elle dit : «Bien,
ça sonne pareil.» J'ai dit :
«Oui, ça sonne pareil!»
- Ça a déjà germé, beaucoup.
- Et au-delà des mots, il y a
tout le non-dit et la manière
de dire les choses qui sont
différents au Japon.
- Un défi de communication,
c'est ça le plus gros défi
qu'on a.
- Pour moi, c'est... Il faut
avoir beaucoup de courage aussi.
Oui, c'est pas toujours facile
pour moi.
- Et le fossé n'est pas que
culturel, il est aussi agricole.
Les saisons ne sont pas
tout à fait les mêmes
et les superficies non plus.
Dans son pays, Tatsuya cultivait
tout seul une parcelle de 1 ha.
En comparaison, la Ferme Cadet
Roussel compte 5 ha de légumes.
- Il faisait déjà de
l'agriculture à petite échelle.
Puis finalement, bien ici,
il trouve qu'on fait de
l'agriculture à grande échelle
par rapport à ce que lui faisait
au Japon.
- Lui, il travaillait beaucoup à
la main. C'est des choses que...
Des fois, il commence à la main,
on dit : «Non, non, on a l'outil
pour ça!» Puis là, c'est sûr
que, vroum vroum!, deux coups de
tracteur, c'est fait! Bon, OK!
Ça fait que des fois, il faut
communiquer un petit peu plus
sur la méthode de culture,
mais en général... Là, c'est
son deuxième été, puis il est
un poisson dans l'eau. C'est
son métier, tu vois que c'est
sa passion. Puis il est plus dur
à arrêter qu'à décoller!
- Jeudi après-midi dans le
quartier Notre-Dame-de-Grâce
à Montréal; c'est jour
de livraison des paniers.
♪ ♪ ♪
- On veut garder les cassots.
- Tu veux garder ça? OK.
-  Comme bien des petits
producteurs maraîchers,
Tatsuya doit maîtriser de
multiples tâches. Il supervise
les champs et veille aussi
à la distribution des légumes.
Yoshie, elle, est responsable de
nourrir familles et travailleurs
au quotidien. Aujourd'hui au
menu : un gratin de pommes
de terre et de choux-fleurs,
avec des légumes de la ferme,
évidemment.
- Je mélange des légumes de
saison et des choses congelées
aussi. Il faut avoir de la place
pour prochains légumes.
♪ ♪ ♪
- L'agriculture biodynamique
demande d'être très à l'écoute
de la nature. La présence aux
champs est donc essentielle;
un rôle qui sied bien à Tatsuya.
- Il passe beaucoup de temps
à observer, prévoir quand
les légumes vont être prêts
pour la récolte.
- Tous les matins, il fait un
tour des champs. Puis, quand
on arrive à la réunion du matin,
il dit déjà : «Ça c'est urgent;
ça, c'est prêt; ça, c'est fait;
ça, c'est à faire.» Il est
vraiment au taquet des cultures.
- Et malgré les défis,
ils retiennent le positif.
- Croiser tout le temps d'autres
cultures, d'autres nationalités,
habiter, partager les moments
ensemble, manger ensemble,
travailler ensemble...
c'est vraiment rare une place
comme ça.
- C'est un peu comme
un autre monde ici!
- Un autre monde où ils
aimeraient bien s'enraciner.
- On aime le Québec, donc
on aimerait très bien habiter
plus longtemps que possible.
♪ ♪ ♪